Як і в кожного старшокласника, у Данила попереду -
серйозні випробування. За рік - іспити ЗНО,
вибір навчального закладу та вступ до вишу.
Поки з професією він ще не визначився,
однак уже знає, де хотів би навчатися.
- Я багато читав
про навчання у Франції.
Ця вся атмосфера французька,
ну і, звичайно, рівень навчання там
буде набагато вищим, ніж у нас.
Здобути освіту за кордоном фінансово може собі
дозволити далеко не кожен український абітурієнт.
За підрахунками аналітичного центру CEDOS,
лише 8% від загальної кількості
українських абітурієнтів обирають для освіти іншу країну.
Витрати на навчання залежать
не лише від спеціальності, але й від обраної країни.
Університети Франції, про які так мріє Данило,
фінансує держава. Студенти вносять лише річні внески.
Залежно від обраної спеціальності і вишу це
від 200 до 500 євро на рік.
Проживання залежить від регіону.
У провінції достатньо буде і 600 євро на місяць,
у столиці - 1500. Це і на житло, й на харчування.
У Франції навчаються близько 1,5 тисячі українців.
Найпопулярнішою країною серед українських абітурієнтів залишається Польща.
За даними польського Інституту публічних справ,
тут навчаються понад 35 000 молодих українців.
Обирають цю країну через менші витрати на житло
та відносно легкий вступ до вишу.
На щомісячні потреби йде приблизно 350 євро, з них 250 - на оренду житла.
Однак на безкоштовну освіту можуть розраховувати
лише ті українці, які мають карту поляка,
що підтверджує польське коріння.
Решті доведеться платити.
У приватному виші це від 900 і більше євро на рік,
у державному - понад 2000 євро.
- Також наші банки пропонують кредити для того,
щоби співфінансувати таке навчання.
Зокрема тоді, коли навчання фінансується
за кредитом, - тільки частково (банк), а частково людина сама платить.
Німеччину обирають переважно студенти, які
прагнуть здобути якісну природничу чи технічну освіту.
Навчається тут близько 7000 українців.
Освіта безкоштовна, але стягуються обов'язкові внески:
у середньому від 150 до 300 євро за семестр.
Сюди, приміром, уже входить проїзний квиток,
утримання кампусів, бібліотечні абонементи
та інші елементи комфорту студентів.
Аби отримати німецьку навчальну візу,
абітурієнт має подати довідку про платоспроможність,
тобто засвідчити, що в разі чого може сам про себе фінансово подбати.
Це немало - 8640 євро.
Найчастіше студенти просто позичають ці гроші,
аби зробити одноразову роздруківку з банківського рахунку.
Утім, хлопця більше лякає інше.
- Фінансування - не головна проблема.
Я вважаю, що головна проблема - це знання мови.
Оскільки середня освіта в Україні триває на рік менше,
ніж у ФРН, німецькі університети пропонують
українським абітурієнтам пройти різні підготовчі курси.
На них і німецьку мову можна підтягти, і вже
націлено готуватися до навчання саме за обраною спеціальністю.
Щоправда, задоволення це - не з дешевих.
- Ціна залежить від того, наскільки добре володіє абітурієнт німецькою мовою.
Десь від шести до десяти тисяч євро.
Але сюди включається пакет з різними додатковими послугами.
Студент із моменту, коли обрав наш університет для вступу,
вже отримує умовну реєстрацію в університеті.
Його можуть також зустріти в аеропорту.
Найкраща можливість для українських абітурієнтів
потрапити на навчання у ФРН - це отримати
стипендію від якогось німецького фонду, яка
покриє витрати на проживання. Адже в Німеччині,
як і скрізь у Європі, основна частина студентських витрат - це житло.
Якщо в Мюнхені можна знайти одну кімнату
від 600 євро на місяць і більше, то
у східних німецьких землях ціни демократичніші.
- Витрати на продукти в Німеччині не дуже високі,
а студентський квиток дає значні переваги:
можна безкоштовно користуватися транспортом,
а у студентських їдальнях ціна на їжу теж не висока.
Загалом офіційна рекомендація для студентів -
це бюджет у 850 євро в місяць.
Батьки Данила заздалегідь почали відкладати гроші на навчання для сина.
Але навіть значних заощаджень не вистачить,
приміром, для такої країни, як Англія.
Там за навчання доведеться заплатити
в середньому 15 000 євро на рік і ще 7 000 - за проживання.
Можна спробувати отримати грант від британського уряду.
Він може включати не лише повну вартість навчання,
а й проживання і навіть перельотів.
Але отримати таку стипендію нелегко:
там величезний конкурс.
А поки батьки думають, де взяти гроші на навчання,
Данило міркує про своє покликання в житті.
- Батько взагалі каже: йди вчи мову програмування.
Я спробував це у 12-13 років.
Боже, це так нудно! Це прописувати безкінечний код,
вишукувати кожну крапочку,
закривати дужки й відкривати їх.
Ні, це не дуже цікаво.
Я не вважаю, що в мене щось вийде в цій професії.
Для мене більш важливо, щоб це було цікаво і я отримував задоволення.
Наразі всі сили Данило спрямовує на вивчення мов:
англійської та французької. Адже рік -
не так і багато часу для підготовки до вступу
у європейський виш та на успішну здачу ЗНО.
На незалежному оцінюванні Данило планує набрати
щонайменше 170 балів.